welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where they all float with
Pennywise making a return to our screens
with it Chapter two I thought I'd
revisit the first film and go over every
scene with a fine-tooth comb to point
out all of the times that Pennywise was
hidden away in the background secretly
watching our characters it's crazy the
amount of times that he pops up and
hopefully this list will enrich in your
love for the film by showing you just
how much of a hold that the killer Klown
has on the town of Derry there will be
some spoilers here in regards to the
movie so if for whatever reason you
haven't seen it yet then I highly
suggest that you turn off now with that
out the way I just want to give a huge
thank you for clicking this video now
let's get into my breakdown of every
time that Pennywise was hidden away in
the background of a scene okay so the
first one comes right at the beginning
of the movie when Georgie is going down
to the basement throughout the house
there are several small images of
Pennywise ingrained into the wallpaper
as Georgie makes his way to the wax and
in a blink and you'll miss a moment that
roughly takes place over two frames you
may also notice his small shiny eyes
watching the young boy at the top of the
stairs as he descends into the basement
whilst he also appears later in the
scene hiding under the stairs this is
the first of many examples that shows
you that he's always one step behind his
prey constantly stalking them and
waiting for the perfect moment to attack
up next is the library scene with Ben in
which there were several minor
appearances by penny wise before he
makes his final play and tries to attack
the character the first one comes in the
form of a creepy librarian that slowly
watches Ben as he reads about the
history of Derry throughout the seen the
mysterious librarian creepily stares at
him smiling as he digs deeper into what
exactly may be going on in the
it's a really haunting scene and it's
something I didn't even pick up on my
first couple of watches though the more
you focus on the background of the scene
the more you realize that Pennywise is
slowly making his play another blink and
you'll miss it moment also happens in
the scene when Ben is flicking through
the book and in a small frame that flies
by so fast you have to screenshot in
order to see it you will see the
children's Easter egg hunt that
infamously ended in disaster in the top
right of the photo when paused you will
notice a blurry vision of Pennywise that
shows that he was the cause behind the
massacre and has been in the town at
several key points
soon after the scene Ben is caught by
Henry Bowers and we see a small balloon
pop up in the back window of a car
during the attack as he calls up a help
this shows that Pennywise has a hold
over the adults in Derry and is
physically controlling them so that they
will appear nonchalant any trouble and
the children in the area get into whilst
this one is rather obvious it adds a
nice amount of subtext to the city and
definitely lets you know that Pennywise
has the ability to reach into pretty
much every aspect of Derry the next one
comes during the scene in which the
losers Club try and help Ben with his
cuts the characters are all leaning up
against a wall with graffiti behind them
which seems innocuous enough until
during the scene Pennywise his face
appears in the markings of watching them
the face definitely isn't there earlier
in the scene so it's safe to say that
this has definitely been done with
something else other than spray paint
it's an awesome little addition that
once again cements just how able
Pennywise is with hunting his prey he
can follow them wherever he wants to and
this makes him infinitely more
terrifying
up next is a rather obvious one but I
thought I'd include it just in case you
missed it June the scene in which the
losers Club all admit and they're afraid
of something we could see a clown on the
stage in the background staring at the
group and when Ritchie says that he
hates clowns the figure reaches out
menacingly to him with a balloon and
from this point on just stares at him
and finally I'll focus on his appearance
in the TV show that seems to be
plastered across every television screen
in Derry whilst Pennywise definitely
appears at the end
taunting Henry to kill his own father if
you go back and watch the movie you will
notice that this show also appears and
the rest of the film firstly Eddie's
mother is sat watching
when the children go out and later when
Beverly sneaks past her father he too is
watching it so it might be just a great
thing to watch right like like the heavy
spoilers show yet
well you can actually hear the woman in
the show say it's okay to go and play in
the sewers it's safe and fun this is of
course telling children to enter penny
wisest domain and to potentially become
his next meal
so yeah it's probably the creepiest
thing out there that anyone could be
watching what makes it clear that this
is all part of penny wisest plan is
cemented by the fact that it's playing
when Beverly sneaks past it then when we
cut back to the TV moments later it's
just playing static so yes something
suspicious is definitely going on here
and that's every time that I know is
penny wise popping up in the background
of a scene in the film obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on this list
did you notice them and have you spotted
any more that I missed out comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of all the
monsters from scary stories to tell in
the dark which would be linked at the
end in it I go about everything you need
to know about the creatures so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
talk to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then you can follow me
on twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see it
over there after this I also just want
to let you know that we're currently
giving away a free copy of John wick
three on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on it in the comment section
below the one will be chosen at random
on September the 10th and the blu-ray
will be shipped out from then to ever
gets the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]